And this is an interesting one
that will start with teams that
just even flip that page a
little bit when we get to this
Tuesday. And it's the Browns,
right? The Cleveland Browns
team has been all kinds of beat
up battle and some weird
injuries, finding ways to win
these close games. They did it
again this week,
but barely and they were going
up against the Ravens team.
That was without Lamar Jackson
for Cleveland. What pages. They
need to turn their what's the
temperature right now with
the Cleveland Browns?
Well, I mean if you're Baker
Mayfield, sometimes you just
need to just keep things
in-house. You don't have to
tell the media every single
thing, every single thought
that you're thinking, you know,
sometimes it's good just to be
quiet and go,
you know, at the end of the day,
I don't know what Baker
Mayfield is talking about taking
a foot off the gas at
the end of the day. I was
watching the defense and
defense was flying around Mi
geared. You Damien clowning
them boys was flying around
making plays and just
you know doing what they're
doing. So,
I don't know what Baker's
talking about at the end of
the day. I think he was really
upset. He's, you know, he got
taken out the game and things
like that. But Baker, needs to
just continue to focus on
playing good quarterback and
stop worrying about everything
else is just too many
distractions with him.
It was going to be more
distractions to because you're
going to have eight players. Now
who are going to enter onto
this covid list, right? Rod and
four of them are going to be
offensive starters. I'll run you
through a few of these
names. You could tell me what
you think. Right now. They're
in a position with all their
meetings being held virtually,
but Jarvis Landry, Wyatt teller,
Austin
Hooper, all three going to be on
that list. How big of a loss
is not going to be as they try
to go win this AFC North, which
is very tight at this point,
especially with Lamar Jackson
a little beat up.
Well Jarvis Landry, he's your
he's a tough guy in the slot.
He makes those tough catches and
not only that. He does
an excellent job in the Run game
blocking, linebackers blocking,
strong, safety us. Why it
teller, obviously, he's
alignment. You don't want to
miss one
of your key lime. And, and who's
the other guy, Austin
Hooper, you know, they like to
run those two and three, tight
end packages all the time and
they paid, this do like 40
something million dollars.
They game of 40 million dollar
deal.
So they expect him to be on the
football field and obviously,
he's not, he's got soft hands.
Good route, Runner, you know.
Austin can do good player.
He sure is at AFC North is going
to be really interesting.
I'll come back next segment. Ask
you, you think winds up
winning the AFC North gets to
our second, one on, Turn
the Page Tuesday, which is the
Jags,
the Jags, and Urban Meyer. I
don't know if you saw that
handshake at the end of the game
with Vrabel, but there
were some dead eyes from Urban
Meyer. He said losing just
sucks the soul out of you,
Jacksonville. Urban Meyer.
What's your take?
I just think it was such a
classless thing. Mike, Vrabel
is a good dude. He's a really
good, dude. I've known Mike for
a long time. Play with him, won
two championships with him. And
for him to treat him like that,
like you go there and you show
a level of class
because you are the leader of
that team and everyone's
looking at you and you still
have to treat people the right
way. Despite going through
adversity. I was very
disappointed. Urban mind. We had
this conversation a few
weeks ago. What should they do?
And you ask
me? I say Well, they're probably
going to keep them
to work with Trevor Lawrence. To
get better.
But my variable did not this.
This is inexcusable right here
from Urban Meyer. The
arrogance. That was so arrogant.
You don't even look
at a head coach of grown, man,
in his eye.
A guy that you supposed to
respect, man, urban urban
Meyer's trash. I will get rid of
them.
I will get rid of them. I will
get rid of them. Because, you
know what? I don't want a guy
like that represent my
organization. If I'm a
billionaire and I own a team,
you think I want that to be my
head coach. I think I want that
to represent the organization
that that I own absolutely not
pay him his money, whatever it
is and get them out of there.
The players don't respect them
and he understands he can't
bring that arrogance. You're
dealing with guys that are
multi millionaires. You can't
come up in there and just think
that
that you're going to be
respected. You got to earn that
respect. These guys are multi
millionaires, just like you
coach, they don't have to be
college. Kids kissing your ass.
They don't have to kiss your
butt.
These guys are Pros so you have
to treat them. I'm such you
can't do the same things that
you did in college. You have to
come here and earn your stripes
and Urban Meyer has not done
that and welcome to the NFL.
I can't say that I disagree with
one word. You just said he
gets into and Marvin Jones jr.
Who we both know, he's one of
the nicest guys that you'll be
around in the NFL a true
Family, Man. A leader guy, who's
done it, multiple
different
places had successful
everywhere. He's been
a leader of that, entire
receiver room, gets into it
with him to where they basically
have two separate
calls, a bunch of his assistant
coaches losers. And here's
the Crazy, Dave Robinson would
say the vast majority,
right? James Robinson, the vast
majority of
People agree with you. Did they
got to move on from Urban Meyer?
I'm not sure shod con does and
Chaka Khan's. Ultimately going
to be the guy who's making this
decision and it continues to
feel like he is going to try
this for another year. I think
there will be changes on that
staff.
I think he will change
drastically, who is assistant
coaches are
but I don't think they wanted
right him some Mega check with
all the guaranteed money for a
half years work. I just don't
see him doing it. I think you're
going to see a second
season with Urban Meyer coaching
Trevor Lawrence in
the Jacksonville Jaguars.
And it's going to be pretty
crazy to see cuz it's only
going to get louder down there
in Jacksonville.
So I'm glad I'm not all know
man.
Yeah. Yeah.
I am too. For more reasons than
just a football team. Let's get
to number 3, the Cowboys
offense.
They've been struggling a little
bit defense. So much
better. What's going on with the
Cowboys offense though. Do
you think?
It's just the chemistry with the
wide receivers, all these
wide receivers. They're not
playing all the time. They're
not practicing. So you just, you
could tell the continuity
to chemistry to trust is off.
And I still think that back is
having some problems with that
leg. Whether it's the calves,
whether it's the previous
injury, he doesn't look right.
He's compensating and he's not
100%. And he wants the more we
talked about how poorly he's
playing
and how badly badly, he looks.
Well, he wants to throw the
ball, even more and then Kellen
Moore as an offensive. He has to
do a better job in
situational,
you know, times not passing the
ball, run the football. I don't
know what it is with these
offensive coordinators. I think
these guys are so hungry to
become head. Coach has the put
up these spectacular numbers.
They just want to pass pass
Pass.
Run the football.
Yeah, I'm with you on the
healthy point. I'm not sure.
Doc has been healthy ever since
that calf injury. So you just
kind of looks like he's limping
out there to me looks like he's
trying to tough his way through
it, but it's not a lot of pop
in his lower body. So let's hear
from Jerry Jones Cowboys
owner.
Here's what he had to say about
Dak Prescott his quarterback
potential health and all that
applies.
Do you think DAC is in a slump
right now?
I don't want to say
that
swamp.
But that's, that's probably
fair,
but it's such a multiple
faceted evaluation,
but I would say that our offense
is definitely
a way from where we were playing
five, and six games ago.
Yeah. Well, first of all, we got
to get Jerry Jones,
a podcast. Ready? Get Of 1053
The Fan there, but let's get
into
some Dak Prescott numbers,
right? So this is how he's
looking first eight games to the
last four games. This is
what it looks like, right? He
comes back and even when he
first started playing Rod,
everyone's going maybe we give
him an extra month to get out
of this. Some pretty brutal
injury that he's working his
way back from. But from very
first game against the bucks.
He was awesome ever. Since that
calf injury though,
been a different story.
Yeah, absolutely. It's been a
different story and that's why
we talked earlier about the
importance of the defense
stepping up and carrying them
Michael Parsons and those guys
Randy Gregory making plays and
the fact that they now have
both their defensive ends back
healthy,
that allows Micah farce Parsons
even more freedom, whether he's
coming off the edge outside of
Gregory, what he's coming in
the middle or dropping in
coverage, it provides them
with, you know, even more. So
I don't know man, what's going
on with the Dallas Cowboys? If
they're going to get back to
running a football or Or what's
going to happen with the
offensive line? It's just been
crazy. But I know one thing that
needs to
may need to evaluate deck and
either
let them rest for a week or two
or you know, he needs he needs
to play. Well, he needs to play
better.